uh mike rappaport's favorite podcast on
youtube it's gonna be here everybody
what hey mike hi mikey
hey dick richie [ __ ] loser yeah if
you guys are enjoying the new intro
great this is what we do we uh you know
we have people that have been working
for us behind the scenes doing stuff and
this is why
we strongly encourage you to go to
patreon.com slash we're not sorry uh
because we're not see we're not lazy
we've been working on [ __ ] everybody's
been put the same thing all the time
we've been working on it see this is
it's nice to debut a new thing some new
production
hold on my production value i'm i'm uh
i'm uh
i'm a fighting with a mike rappaport's
kid on twitter right now what the [ __ ] i
don't know look it's clearly him so then
i just called him out by the way he's
like oh i'm 17 i'm like yeah and then i
said the page six article you were 17 to
2017. you believed page six i'm like
yeah i do yeah so um hey by the way mike
you want to start you want to first the
first thing is that when he's fighting
and going oh yeah you're really going to
pick on this you're like first of all
you're larping as a kid you're not
you're not a kid you're not a little kid
you're trying to make us scare you're
doing the old cassandra fairbanks as we
call it
i was underage shut up stupid um here's
the thing bud um
it's it's it's still 17 is still much
older uh than the average age of the
kids that the producers you work for
[ __ ]
come on mikey
you could pretend to be your kid but
you're not uh it's been trying to talk
to this this is a message i was i was
actually the grocery store and i get
this message it's of dean rappaport at
mike
rappaport's son which isn't his son by
the way it's a larping account uh we've
already found a page six article mike
rappaport has been larping as his son
since 2017. yeah for those of you that
don't know mike rappaport's uh real uh
his son's real twitter account is at not
right rappaport's son right
that's that's mean
um so uh now he's not going to call in
as i go we're calling calling the show
right now he's not going to call in of
course because uh he is a
[ __ ]
uh there you go mikey boy what's wrong
mike uh got the number bud and he was
like uh yeah of course i'm not i'm not
gonna call any [ __ ] show and i'm not
gonna what am i gonna do i'm gonna make
you guys more famous
shut up guy call in or don't don't
[ __ ] don't yeah don't [ __ ] up larping
it's embarrassing mike take that weak
[ __ ] out of here when we're getting
ready for a show running around trying
to [ __ ] do [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
kryptos doing its thing trying to make
coffee running errands by the way shout
out uh to uh the big homie uh i don't
know if you want something to name them
but the the gentleman who sent in those
uh the mics and the hard drive stuff
thank you sorry so we went to head to
the p.o box so we were running around
man okay we don't have time for you
shenanigans if if if you want to call in
mike it's not it's not it's not you and
by the way yeah
because he actually wrote oh you you
called the 17 year old sweetie what he
catch a predator and i'm like yeah then
i posted the paid six you've been 17
since 2017. cut the [ __ ] so either call
or don't call but you know what's sad is
the guy in true romance has a google
alert for himself and then he watches
youtube videos about himself and then he
larps online so this this was a message
you were by the way the least memorable
part of that movie
so here's the message i'm serious
message me your number i want to talk to
you right now about my dad michael
rappaport michael rappaport this is
really him replies dean what are you
talking about aren't you in school
please get off your phone now um dean
rappaport no these guys are racist and
literally said the most disgusting thing
about you and your family you and our
family i'm handling it please get off
your phone while you're in school mom is
gonna pick you up after volleyball
practice this is so weird then michael
rappaport pretending to be dean
rappaport wrote i quit volleyball i
haven't played volleyball since october
i don't want your life
i'm serious message me your number
uh message me uh
message me your number
uh i want to talk to you right now about
my dad and then he go dean what are you
talking about please get off your phone
uh then this go to the dms real quick he
writes hey [ __ ] what's your number once
i figured out it was him and by the way
merch helped me out with this reply come
on mike that bit is hack even for you
this is the worst acting i've seen since
your performance in deep blue c that was
me so it was mean royce royce came up
with that on his own i'm not i'm not
taking responsibility for that i
wouldn't take responsibility either i i
uh
i'm not going to get beat up by a 50
year old wigger who's having an identity
crisis in his 50s i'm not doing that but
so you keep so so let me let me go to my
dms here real quick and by the way mike
i know all your la comic buddies at the
comedy store i know they all dress like
wiggers but they still talk like white
guys come on so then um mike rappaport's
son which is actually mike rappaport
writes come on mike this bit is hack
even for you this is the worked act
worst acting i've seen since your
performance in deep blue sea he goes i
will literally call you right now and
you will hear that this isn't a bit
what's your number tubby i replied show
starts in 10 minutes wigger you can call
in when we're live he writes nobody
listens to your show fat boy well you do
or i'm sorry your dad does
uh just give me your mother's landline
because it looks like you live in her
basement oh
he was in koplan [ __ ] owned some cop
land so you're not gonna call figures
not to promote your stupid show you talk
about my father you could talk to me
personally on the phone without your
little camera crew and microphone camera
crew god i wish [ __ ] what are we [ __ ]
who are we louis jay gomez
i'll call you before the show sounds
good mr diabetes i wrote oh mikey
you never will i know it's okay give me
a second i'll give you my number lol so
you can report it record it get the [ __ ]
outta go oh what's wrong mike you scared
sweetie you're literally saying sweetie
with 17 year old i think i'll see you on
to catch a predator you'll never make it
out of orlando that's trying to be
scared oh you know where you live it
says it in my bio uh you were seven and
then of course i wrote you were 17 in
2017 what's this mike page six oh that's
right is michael rappaport arguing with
his son on twitter uh this is january 26
2017 actor michael rappaport doesn't
want his son using his phone at school
even stick up for his father so you go
to his timeline this is what the bit is
or so has appeared on thursday morning
twitter user claimed to be teenage son
of actor came to the defense uh when
journalists alex leo and lindsey
robertson criticized him for taking aziz
ansari to task comparing chris brown to
donald trump in his saturday night live
monologue uh the whole thing started
when leo and robertson asked on twitter
ryrappa46 was so insulted by ansari's
joke robertson suggested it was because
uh
michael rappaport has his own criminal
history with women to worry about
i would pretend to be a 17 year old too
if you had your own criminal history
with women mike uh what was the season
ansari's joke was did it have a damn in
it yeah probably okay and michael
rappaport got mad because he was ripping
him off he's like man we all hate that
donald trump am i right you know i know
kanye west that's some real [ __ ] she
also linked to an article detailing a
1998 incident when the actor admitted to
harassing ex-girlfriend lily taylor how
dare you talk about my father everyone
has a bad day you girls are so cute
spewing that hate on twitter an account
under the name of dean rappaport tweeted
before you two are the reason i get
bullied at school you know nothing you
know no no nothing about my dad so
michael rappaport is been doing this
since
2017.
since
2017
he's been pretending
he's been pretending
uh
to uh
to be his son you know on twitter to
fight with people if if you um
if you had uh
you have a z sensory and you have
michael rappaport if you had lily sing
in this article you'd have the brown
face strike fecta you would
at least [ __ ] at least the other two are
closer to [ __ ] black than here well i
don't want to say black for yeah you
know uh aziz and sorry who
who the [ __ ] do you think you are
dragging chris around through the mud
a lot of you know i graduated top of my
class in the navy seriously rappaport
also criticized that sorry for taking on
race in america in both his comedy and
the later shows master of none okay [ __ ]
you little politically correct [ __ ] he
said i'm not saying he's not funny i'm
not saying he's not talented and i'm not
saying his voice isn't warranted but
you're not holier than thou
so
michael rappaport's son by the way you
got caught because at for for for a
couple i was in the grocery store i was
like oh [ __ ] it's really a son so be on
your stroke i'm not gonna have to say i
wrote i did tweet i'm not gonna have a
17 year old on my show man i'm not gonna
do that but then but then
i realized it was him and i'm like oh
what's up mike you got caught huh you
got caught larping this is embarrassing
this is very embarrassing [ __ ]
embarrassing and there's a story out
there let me can i tell you a michael
rappapor story sure one that i found
online
and you could you could check it for
yourself in the deep blue sea if you
happen to be one of the four people that
owned the deep blue sea blu-ray
it has commentary uh it has commentary
by um
samuel l jackson
samuel l jackson uh was uh was in the
movie
and he apparently said
that you know sam jackson ll coolidge
were the other two guys in the movie
michael rappaport was in the movie and
during the breaks michael rappaport keep
walking up to them
and talking to them about hip hop and
rap and stuff like that to where sam
jackson had to remind michael rappaport
that you're white
leave me alone
so just so you know that's really that's
that's that's
that's who michael rappaport kind of you
know when you told me that story last
night it kind of reminded me of uh
remember the scene in airheads
when adam sandler was like first off
mike i remember all the scenes in your
house he's like hey man by the way we're
down man hendricks was god
and the black guy is just like
it was the black guy from the wire too
with the big afro so he's using a larpi
account he's using a larpi account
a fake account of his son to defend
criminal allegations that were made
against him just i want to really get
this down
can i get this out of the way though
mike if you i know you're watching right
now i know you're watching of course
you're going to pretend like you didn't
but you're watching
maybe spend can i just tell put your hat
straight first i know it's true i know
it's sideways and stop slouching okay i
assume you're slouching uh
and probably wearing some kind of
throwback 76ers
i don't know i just wanna i could have
easily went next i wanted something a
little more uh but listen mike word of
advice right
it's um it's been like i don't know
15 20 years since you've been in a movie
anybody's seen nobody saw uh uh once
upon a time in queens with [ __ ] chess
palminteri nobody saw any of this [ __ ]
not even chess palmitary a little word
of advice okay um
maybe a little more time going to
auditions
a little less time larping is your uh
23 probably 23 year old son at this
point on twitter uh just a thought
you're not you're at a point now where
you're not above going to auditions
again and humbling yourself and maybe if
you did that and you spent less time
[ __ ] around running uh
doing periscope videos and trying to get
comedians canceled you might have more
than just a shitty netflix show that
people only know exists because they
logged into netflix to watch episodes of
friends
i they would rather watch like repeats
of what people are logging in there to
watch friends and old episodes of star
trek [ __ ] the next generation instead
of your brand new show
so um mike you got caught you got caught
blarping you got caught you got caught
you were gonna call me you were gonna
call but here's the thing the moment i
said hey man why don't you
call in the show then call the show
call the show
um big big tough guy you big tough guy
big tough guy who the [ __ ] guy dick
is out there being racist all the time
this [ __ ] president's an [ __ ]
that's all you do mike you're a [ __ ]
you're just you're a male you're a 50
year old male
wigger version of alyssa milano that's
what you are last known photo of him i
was really famous in the 90s and now i'm
just saying you're [ __ ] yelling a lot
of periscope
enough
this is the last known photo of him
that was back when he had all the bling
and all the money yeah when he was when
he was still coasting and getting all
that [ __ ] uh dick richie puss
yeah you [ __ ] thank you why did you
shut the [ __ ] up yonkers most wanted
oh my god are you so uh this is
apparently his fake father's account
which to me is a bad taste considering
that these are allegations of abuse
which honestly this me too error mike
you got to be careful man you got to be
careful you know yeah i'm sure you're
not a man who understands 2fa very well
and by the way larping as a 17 year old
uh and then telling people oh you're
literally talking to servitude girl that
way didn't you do like a movie with
woody allen the guy who married his 17
year old stepdaughter
you work for people who [ __ ] literal
children here's the thing mike if some
17 year old says
gets in my face i'm going to tell him to
go [ __ ] himself i don't care if hey if a
10 year old got my face started talking
[ __ ] i'd tell him to go [ __ ] himself
here's the beauty of that there's no law
against that yeah okay this is the same
thing like you can't like you use you're
gonna hide behind this fake minor [ __ ]
where yeah i mean i'm of course if i'm
trying to [ __ ] you or i'm flashing my
dick at you or i'm sharing my [ __ ] my
booze with you sure i can get in trouble
there is no law on the books anywhere in
any country that i can't tell a 17 year
old to go [ __ ] himself so go [ __ ]
yourself and if it on the off let's say
we're raw let's just operate for one
second under the assumption that we're
wrong and it's really a 17 year old hey
17 year old
go [ __ ] yourself
hey you like them apples there's nothing
you could do about it
so this is him larping as his kid um
[ __ ]
seriously you know what you are you're a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] jew from new
york who talks and acts like a [ __ ]
black guy and you're in your 50s you're
a [ __ ] discount off brand mc search
that's what you are you are mc search
without a gold record you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] well his full name is mc
searching for work
oh [ __ ] mc searching for new
representation
so it's okay and by the way mc searching
for a holding deal
don't hit don't hit women all right man
i think that's the thing yeah don't
stalk women and don't like that don't
hurt women okay yeah i don't know if you
hear but you know don't be so stalky and
creepy you know no means no mike
you know this is the me too can i let me
do it in his style sure
it's it's a metoo movement now
[ __ ] you can't just be out here
disrespecting women like that if they
say no you gotta leave them alone bro
uh
so this is uh he's been doing this for a
while he needs to stop doing all of this
and i mean all of it including existing
he needs to stop
he has been doing this bit for a while
and listen mike
little man you got caught
admit you got caught admit you got admit
you got caught doing a bad bit
admit that you're just embarrassing now
and you know mike i get it bro i get it
what ari did was terrible but already's
never been accused of doing anything to
women has he can you look that up can
you see if harry's ever done anything to
women um i mean
i wouldn't commit to that until he said
yes can you pull that up jamie
why i asked her i don't think so though
no that's why i asked ari ari is one of
those guys
uh who does absolutely shitty [ __ ] to
like his guy come here
but i yeah no there's nothing literally
under controversies on wikipedia it's
only the kobe bryant thing okay and
again i mean a lot of people have said
that i mean i would i would argue that
dosing for crutcher should also be under
controversial yeah i guess but i'm just
saying i'm be fair i want to be fair
here but uh you know it other than that
i mean a lot of people have said over
time that ari fear is not a bad duties
you know especially in the world of
stand-up com and that's the other thing
i love is that they're trying to go like
this fear is such a piece of [ __ ] you're
like who in stand-up comedy
is not a piece of [ __ ] right like it's
just i guess it just depends on who
you're friends with or whatever or who's
nice to you and who's not but you can
find any comedian that some guy will you
can find comedians that we like that we
say are nice like louis j gomez i'm sure
you can find 10 people that would go
that guy's a piece of [ __ ] he's the
worst human being that ever lived right
10 people in gas digital that would say
that are there right now
they're all in the building no but like
you know again but it's not
you know it's again everybody has people
that are like [ __ ] that guy what a piece
of [ __ ] but overall when most people are
like no he's a pretty good dude he's
never
you know
he's never [ __ ] pulled his dick out
blocked the door and started jerking off
yeah
so when you search old wigger look at
these look at page two oh my god look
all i searched was old waker so you
could take a look hold he search old
wigger and there he is michael rappaport
you're an old wigger mike and it's
embarrassing and it's from the root so
that means black people hate you mike
stop stop pandering stop
old wigger uh stop [ __ ]
stop [ __ ] uh uh trying to be a part
of a culture that wants nothing to do
with you from the root michael rappaport
is the worst kind of white man
worst kind of white man also
some cult
weird placement for cold sores there
mike uh always got herps yeah he's got
like you know what it is too he's got
like spinal tap herpes where it's just
ever present it's just always there
uh
the story of the scorpion and the frog
is an ancient african proverb that
explains the importance of knowing whom
to trust and the story okay i'm not
going to make it to the part the frog is
worried but you're prop
okay uh it says you're but you promised
a squirrel okay michael rappaport is a
cool ass white dude everybody knows cool
white dude they listen to hip hop they
know how to speak urban
sometimes they even embed themselves so
deep in black culture that black people
might start believing the cool ass white
dude is somehow immune to the disease of
racism mike
it's not working
on sunday before appearing on an episode
of bravo's watch what happens live the
half chewed marshmallow center of racism
more posted and then deleted a picture
of the real housewives of atlanta
actress kenyon moore alongside a full
photo
of a gorilla
[Laughter]
oh
during the episode rappaport tried to
the former miss usa by announcing i
didn't want to say it live on tv but
kenya's feet are ashy as [ __ ]
he continued them shits are ashy i
didn't want to say it on tv because i'm
a gentleman
uh he really does think he's black like
that's that's that's [ __ ] kind of
like the difference between us and
michael rappaport we'll make that joke
of course i'll make that joke
but the difference is i'm not trying to
embed myself into black culture
yeah i also wouldn't deliver that line
like i was on bet's comic view yeah yo
them shits are so ashy dog
what a cringe old man so there's like
i'm i'm embarrassed for him right now i
was embarrassed from yesterday now i'm
like [ __ ] doubly embarrassed for him
and the whole thing look i'm not gonna
call to promote your show well first off
mike if it's really you
then it's embarrassing but if it's
really your ki which it's not his kid by
the way of course it's but if it is your
kid you're not gonna no one knows who
the [ __ ] you are who you're promoting
but you're not gonna call in the show
mikey boy yeah if it was really mike
rappaport's kid like we said and it's
not um nobody would give a [ __ ] nobody
would go holy [ __ ] you guys we got you
know understand the people we've managed
to get on the show
you know what i mean like we've had john
mcafee on this show we've had some big
[ __ ] names on this show you think
that people are gonna go holy [ __ ] how
did you guys land michael rappaport's
kid people wouldn't even ask holy [ __ ]
how did you land mike rappaport you know
what i mean like that's like are you
[ __ ] kidding me and mike look i
get it i get the fat dude how did you
guys get mike rappaport on the air i'll
tell you how he paid his boost mobile
bill yeah
oh man oh i'm tubby i'm fat okay listen
here 50 year old wigger at least my
original wife's with me so i don't want
to [ __ ] hear it from you homeboy yeah
that's right that's right my wife loves
me uh unlike you and obviously i'm gonna
tell you something i don't know if you
really have kids but if i was them i'd
be [ __ ] embarrassed of wigger dad
like that is [ __ ] embarrassing let me
tell you something mike you think black
people are friends with you i'm sure he
hangs out with black people like dude
you have a lot of black friends i know
you do i have black friends but i'm
always myself i'm never something i'm
not right i'm always myself
i act like me and joke around i don't
pretend to be something i'm not
he's a dude who probably black people
like yeah yeah yeah michael you
hilarious dog you hilarious dog and as
soon as he leaves they go
you believe this guy yeah do you see him
coming over your waist talking to us
well it's also like you know they they
do like i've had to break some wiggerish
tendencies and some habits but like even
at my wiggeriest it's like you know
you've been an actor your whole you're a
jew actor from new york who has never
not been acting like you've had a pretty
charm
so like
people don't buy that [ __ ] from you
they'll only buy it from the guy that's
in the car on the way to go do some dirt
with them you know what i mean people
that get people that will vouch for you
and go yeah no i've seen him do some
wild [ __ ] like don't [ __ ] play with
him but all you do is make periscope
videos try to get people canceled and
whine about the president
oh somebody sent me something
is this true
oh give me give me a give me a second uh
we got breaking breaking information
coming into the uh uh revenge of the cis
news desk right now our correspondent
royce lopez is trying to corroborate
this information
royce do you have any updates uh uh from
from the field
thanks mike i'm out here on the field
and um i just wanted to
it's been
500 years of media and they still can't
figure out that delay i have less of a
delay when i have dusty bogan on and
he's in australia by the way the only
thing you missed a little bit is while
the person's talking you're supposed to
be going
huh
thanks tom did you know michael
rappaport actually tweeted a joke making
light of sexual assault pedophilia and
innocent children almost dying now
remember i don't care if you make those
jokes but when you're gonna criticize
someone like ari for his jokes
fact one did you know michael rappaport
was sentenced in the court of law for
harassing a woman fact too did you know
i'd have 47 year old michael rappaport
once publicly and falsely alluded to
having sex with his 19 year old
co-worker fact three did you know that
michael rappaport insinuated engaging in
a sexual assault on twitter fact four
did you know michael rappaport played a
sp plays a special need father on
atypical yet maliciously uses the awful
term [ __ ] to disparage people now i
call people retards i think michael
rappaport is a [ __ ] i think whoever i
think whoever wrote this article is also
a [ __ ] correct
but i'm not on the show atypical now am
i exactly uh did you know that michael
rappaport is holy hell the hypocrisy and
this one is incredible what is this one
i have to click it i don't know
michael rappaport tells people to vote
or shut the [ __ ] up then why do public
records show
he hasn't voted
since 2002
oh
what's that on your [ __ ] bottom lip
there mikey boy
huh what's up i might be tubby but jesus
christ i don't have herpes
yeah he's got like a bad situation going
on
uh
did you know michael rappapo did you
know that michael rappaport gleefully
admits to uninvitingly touching an
actress breast while on a movie set
michael
i'm shocked quite frankly i'm sure
and i'm appalled
this is the sort of uh can i do it royce
this is the sword why did obs disconnect
no it's it's
we good
it's about to reconnect hold on
you know this is uh definitely
i'm just talking just in case that uh
we're not disconnected which it does do
that sometimes we're back
but um sorry i don't know i got
disconnected guys but we're back very
weird um but if you don't mind where i
said like to just
use a a term that people like mike
rappaport in their circles like to use
this is extremely
problematic behavior mike
very ashamed it is
it is problematic behavior and i don't i
don't really i for one
i don't agree with it do you agree with
this problematic behavior no quite
frankly it's gross and as somebody as
the as the grandson of holocaust
survivors uh personally i'm really
offended
i don't remember that i'm the grandson
of gay holocaust survivors so hold on
they're gay holocaust survivors
so you're like [ __ ] magneto's kid yep
[Laughter]
yeah my name is you know i was this
close to being named cerebro
magneto magneto cerebro
did uh oh sorry sorry we got cut off the
first second but don't worry about it
guys because we have more
did you know michael rat did you know
michael rappaport gleefully admits to
unwillingly touching an actress's breast
did you know that michael rappaport
publicly shames random women and calls
them pigs and animals and other
derogatory terms
really does michael rappaport do that
did you know also you know i want to
point it out falcor versus gene worked
in the chat
uh maybe if michael was more like drexel
and less like dick richie
he could pull off the wigger thing a
little better but i think that should
highlight that
gary oldman in in in
with his hands tied behind his back in
one little movie
did a wigger better in a movie than
you've been doing for 50 years uh did
you know that michael rappaport did you
know that michael rappaport possibly
alluded to comparing a black woman to a
monkey gorilla was it gorilla it was too
gorilla do you think when uh gary oldman
was doing that character anyway he must
have thought it was white boy day you
think he was talking about you think he
used mike rappaport as inspiration for
that line so here's the problem with
this look i would i honestly don't have
a i don't have an issue with like 90 of
the things on this list you know i
wouldn't give a [ __ ]
uh michael rappaport also said this joke
in 2018 i haven't seen someone try to
get a thai boy out of a hole this
frantically since i walked in on kevin
spacey in the men's room at chuck e
cheese
now
here's the thing with this mike um it's
not even a good joke it's not a good
joke but that's not even the point what
what was the hole in the bathroom
was it his whole no the typewide of a
hole i remember when those kids were
stuck in the cave i know the joke
doesn't work because kevin spacey tries
to get into little boys holes not out of
them
you got a picture
yeah this joke's a mess i bet you know
what by the way he wrote that and he
wanted to get like he was like yeah man
owning it i want to write an anonymous
comedian but even if it was a good joke
the point is is that you made a joke
like this making fun of kevin spacey who
you know what destroyed some kids lives
yeah it's not cool bro that's you know
that's really messed up because i'm i'm
just i'm gonna i'm gonna virtue
something like he did with the ari of
course yo bro yo dog that's like [ __ ]
up dude let go you're gonna sit there
you're like the [ __ ] kid's got rape
dawg yo why the [ __ ] making jokes about
[ __ ] kids get [ __ ] in the ass dude
you know what i mean there's a lot of
victims out there of [ __ ] sexual
assault childhood victims okay and
you're [ __ ] out you're making light
of this [ __ ] you might as well be
[ __ ] duh [ __ ] donald trump [ __ ]
grab him by the [ __ ] guy
i'm getting really into doing rap report
now but frankly mike that is and i'm
going to say it again
problematic
so um jesus christ he is not looking
good he's not a
guy that the camera loves no or
directors or producers or casting agents
or black people
or previous relationships
and possibly his children
uh
so mike
not you mike but uh mr mr rappaport
we done here
we done
we finished yeah go back because you're
not gonna blackball me i'm not a [ __ ]
comedian in l.a what i'm i can't go play
at the comedy store i don't give a [ __ ]
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do to me seriously mike
what i said we meant and i will double
down on it you're a [ __ ] hypocrite
and the fact that you're larping as your
kid to fight beefs
is probably one of the cringiest things
i've ever seen anybody do now he's
trying to pretend that it's not him but
it's him and now everybody knows it's
you and everybody will always know it's
you because guess what mike you
are a hack you've always been a hack
you'll always be a hack
okay we're done good now why don't you
go lar why don't you go [ __ ] larp as
your ex-wife so maybe she doesn't
[ __ ] sue you yeah um and i i just
want to point out to you our hack is
what i said but you know what the most
disappointing thing is
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i gave him the number he has the
no but he has the number now i'd call
into any of your dumb [ __ ] and by the
way i wouldn't even do it for clout like
i wouldn't even call in and go you got
to promote my show i call in as an
anonymous nobody and i'd [ __ ] smash
you you dumb [ __ ] failed actor you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] who hasn't done a
goddamn thing of note since 1999. since
you're in a movie with llc you should
[ __ ] stop hello cool j's had hit
songs since the last time you've been in
any good movies hey yo dog trump sucks
do you like me now black people
will you do you like me now yo how
[ __ ] much do i gotta pander you
people i mean i didn't mean you people
but you know when i mean us people
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you mike oh [ __ ] with you with your
little with your little google alerts
set up so you can see when people
mention you
how [ __ ] i don't have one of those
set up no god no i don't have one of
those i don't even listen when people
come to me and go this guy's talking
about you i'm like i don't care playing
video games
i don't really care right now
so there you go michael rappapor we good
hold on we good dog
dog we good
yeah okay good go back to [ __ ]
watching uh reruns of the real
housewives or whatever the [ __ ] you're
doing right now on your couch hip-hop
the real hip-hop wives of atlanta or
whatever yeah seriously go do that
wigger
uh you want to move on yeah that felt
good though all right good you had your
shot mikey
you had your shot do it you blew it just
like you [ __ ] blew your acting career
five dollars you guys suck my father is
the arbiter of comedy that was from mean
dean rappaport
i mean
i would rather have dean malenko on the
show starman622 to be fair dick richie
was the bomb on t.j hooker
mexi max and cheese you're wrong michael
rappaport doesn't work for kid [ __ ]
anymore they don't even want him maybe
that's why he larps as a kid
chewie yo is rappaport catfishing you
wow cruise ship flashbacks also uh more
people watch his episode of friends on
netflix then his more people watch his
episode of friends on netflix than his
new show oh
rotc is dope son that was from kobe
bryant's ghost wow thank you kobe and
you know what
i got to admit man you were one of the
greatest of all time bro
you were hey
why don't you go take some helicopter
lessons
all right